[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم في حصاد الليله معكم زين
العابدين توفيق وفي الوقت الذي احدثكم فيه
تتفاعلوا احداث وتقع اخرى والبدايه من غزه
التي شهرت اليوم قمع قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي مظاهرات القربى الشريط الحدودي
الشرقيه القطاع
[موسيقى]
الحدود الارمنيه الاذربيجانيه وهذه الصور
مباشره من هناك شهدت اليوم نزوح المزيد من
ارمل كارابا الى ارمينيا العدد ربما بلغ
ثلاثين الفا
هذه نيويورك التي اوضنا الامم المتحده
وهناك اختتمت اليوم اعمال الجمعيه العامه
للامم المتحده بتحذير انطونيو من سباق
تسلح النووي جديد يمكن ان يؤدي لفناء
البشريه
وفي مواضيع الحصاد هذه الليله
تحدد مسارات ما بعد اعلان باريس سحب
قواتها المتحدث باسم المجلس العسكري يقول
للجزيره انه لا توجد مشكله مع قوات الدول
الاخرى والمجلس لم يطلب قوات بديله عن
القوات الفرنسيه وباريس تقول ان بازون هو
رئيس النيجر الوحيد والمنتخب ديمقراطيه
مع فرار قرابه الثلاثين الفا من ارمله
خلال ايام لينكن يشدد في اتصال مع الرئيس
الاذربيجاني على وجوب حمايه مدني الاقليم
اذربيجان تؤكد ان الفرصه سانحه للمضي قدما
في التطبيع مع ارمينيا والاتحاد الاوروبي
يرى محادثات بين الطرفين في بروكسان
[موسيقى]
في لقائده اليوميه قبل الحصاد على منصاتنا
الرقميه ناقشنا تحذير كوريا الشماليه من
سباقي صلح نووي في شبه جزيره الكوريه ما
يؤدي ربما الى خطر اندلاع حرب نوويه وحملت
المسؤوليه في ذلك ما وصفته بعدائيه
الولايات المتحده
لاستطاع ارائكم بشار هذا الموضوع كنا قد
طرحنا عليكم السؤال التالي فرايكم
تصريحات كوريا الشماليه من حرب نوويه
وجاءت الردود على النحو التالي
34% قالوا انها مجرد اتهامات هدفها
السياسي في اطار السجل مع واشنطن عشرون
بالمئه قالوا انها اشاره على اقتراب شبه
جزيره الكوريه بالفعل من حرب النوويه
الاكثريه سته واربعون بالمئه اعتبروها
رسائل لخصومه هدفها اظهار نوع من توازن
القوه
هذا السؤال سيبقى مطروحا على منصه الرقميه
ويمكنكم دخول صفحه التصويت عبر مسح رمز
الكيو ار الظاهر على الشاشه
لقائنا على المنصات الرقميه يتجدروا يوميا
وانا التطرق خلاله لقضايا مستجده ومتفاعله
عربيا ودوليا
وتتابعون في الحصاد ايضا
قاده الجيوش من ثلاثين دوله على راسها
الولايات المتحده يجتمعون في الهند لبحث
التهديدات في اسيا
[موسيقى]
البدايه من النيجر وفي حديث للجزيره قال
الناطق الرسمي باسم المجلس العسكري وزير
الشباب والرياضه والثقافه العقيد عبد
الرحمن عمادو ان المجلس لم يتسلم حتى الان
اي بيان رسمي بشان انسحاب القوات الفرنسيه
من بلاده في مقابلته مع الجزيره اضافه
المتحدث العسكري ان المجلس لم يطلب اي قوه
بديله للجنود الفرنسيين
لقد سمعنا بهذا الموضوع من خلال وسائل
الاعلام الفرنسيه حين اعلن الرئيس ماكرون
سحب سفيره وقوات بلاده ونحن كحكومه ومجلس
وطني ننتظر ان يستتبع هذا الاعلان ببيان
رسمي وكذلك الفتن النظر الى انه بالنسبه
الى انسحاب القوات الفرنسيه يجب ان يحصل
ذلك ضمن اطار يتم التفاوض عليه من اجل
الضمان نجاحه وفعاليته وحتى الان لم يردنا
اي بيان او اعلان رسمي بشان هذا الموضوع
اكد ايضا الناطق الرسمي باسم المجلس
العسكري في النيجر العقيده عبد الرحمن
عمادو في مقابلته مع الجزيره انه لا توجد
اي مشكله مع قوات الدول الاخرى في النيجر
ولن يطلب منها الانسحاب
فيما يتعلق بقوات الدول الاخرى في النيجر
فعلى حد علمي لا توجد اي مشكله معها ليست
لدينا اي مشكله مع القوات الاخرى وكالعاده
نحن نعمل مع من يرغب في العمل معنا بطريقه
تعاونيه هذا ما قلناه دائما واحب ان اشير
هنا بان فرنسا هي التي قررت وقف التعاون
معنا ما دفعنا الى انهاء ذلك التعاون الذي
كان يجمعنا بها لكن القوات الاخرى لم تعلق
التعاون معنا وبالتالي لا داعي لان نطلب
انسحابها
الهيبه ولد الشيخ السيدات في الخبير في
الشان الافريقي استاذ الهيبه اهلا وسهلا
بك بدايه ماذا نقرا في تصريحات المتحدث
العسكري
بعدم وجود مشكله مع القوات الاخرى
الموجوده في النيجر الالمانيه والامريكيه
وايضا عدم طلب قوات اخرى لتحل محل القوات
الفرنسيه
مرحبا واهلا هذا تصريح واضح على اختلاف
الاجندات الغربيه في ملف النيجر الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه والمانيا من اول يوم
يقفان موقفا مختلفا عن الموقف الفرنسي
فرنسا كما قال المتحدث ايضا هي التي
دفعتهم
عن شهيتها برفضها للانقلاب هذه المره الى
ان يكونوا في هذا الموقف بالتالي فعلا
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه اتخذت فيتوما
الانقلاب اليون الجدد في النيجر ضد
فاجنر وبالتالي تحاول حمايه النيجر من هذه
الانسحاب اليوم للقوات المسلحه القوات
الفرنسيه من النيجر له دلاله خاصه هذا او
اخر دوله من دول الساحل عضوي لاكواس تنسحب
منها القوات الفرنسيه اذا ليس لم يبقى اي
وجود للقوات الفرنسيه على الارض لهذه دول
الساحل الاعضاء
وبالتالي يهود دلالات واضحه وقويه جدا
ايضا المتحدث العسكري اكد بشكل واضح انه
لن يطلب من اي قوات اخرى ان تحل محل
القوات الفرنسيه هذه رساله لمن يعني خصوصا
ان هنالك مخاوف ربما غربيه من توغل
وامتداد روسي او صيني في افريقيا عموما
وفي هذه المنطقه خصوصا
هذه رساله طمانه واضحه للولايات المتحده
الامريكيه انكم ما دام موقفكم تغير ولم
تربطوا سياستكم الخارجيهم منا بالموقف
الفرنسي فنحن ايضا لن نشرا ولن نقدم خطوه
باتجاه الروس بالتالي لم يطلبوا استعاده
كما حصل في مالي ولا بوركينا فاسو بالتالي
هم تعاطي مختلف وربما هذا يعود لان
انقلابي النيجر من الناحيه التجربه ومن
ناحيه العمر اعمق واقدر على اداره مثل هذه
الملفات الشائكه من الشباب الذين عملوا
انقلابات في مالي وبوركينا فاسو لهذه
الحكمه هي التي جعلتهم يعملون على وجود
اختراق داخل الموقف الغربي وما نجحوا فيه
بالفعل
مطروده وامريكا مرحبا بها ولا يضع خطا
امام اي تحركات فرنسيه افريقيه لسيما انه
المتحدثه باسم الخارجيه الفرنسيه قالت
ان فرنسا ستدعم جهود الاكواس لاستعاده
الدستور نظام الدستوري في النيجر وطبعا
المقصود بذلك اعاده بزوم للسلطه
التدخل العسكري لم يعد مطروحا ما دامت
فرنسا الموجوده على الارض تفكر في
الانسحاب وبالتالي وامريكا اصبحت لديها
ضمانات واضحه من الانقلاب قضيه الكلام
قضيه التدخل العسكري قضيه كلام فقط من اول
يوم الواضح انها مجرد كلام لاكواس لم
تستطع التدخل في مالي ولا في بوركينا فاسو
نفس المسلسل نفس المسلسل الذي بدا في مالي
ببوركينا فاسو يحصل الان في النيجر بدايه
انحصار اقتصادي تهديد بالتدخل دون انسحاب
للقوات الفرنسيه وطرد لها هذا هو ما حصل
فرنسا اصبحت مهزومه في هذه المنطقه بفعل
عن جاهيه ماكرون فعل تعاليه على الافارقه
وعلى المنطقه الساحل
اشكرك شكرا جزيلا الافريقي
[موسيقى]
الان الى اقرباخ قالت الحكومه الارمنيه ان
اكثر من ثمانيه وعشرين الفا من سكان
الاقليم دخلوا الى الاراضي الارمنيه اثناء
وبعد المواجهات العسكريه الاخيره بين
اذربيجان وارمد الاقليم وياتي هذا في ظل
مخاوف ارمنا من التعرض لما يصفونه بانتقام
السلطات اذربيجان اذا بقوا في الاقليم
سياسيا بدا حراك غربي لتطبيع العلاقات بين
اربينيا واذربيجان وهو محور محادثات بين
الجانبين في بروكسل برعايه الاوروبيه
واعلنت مديره الوكاله الامريكيه للتنميه
ان واشنطن ستقدم مساعدات انسانيه لسكان
كارابا وفي المقابل اجر الرئيس الايراني
ابراهيم رئيسي محادثات مع نظير الرسيفر
بوتين بشان الوضع في كندا
فرصه تاريخيه لتطبيع العلاقات بين
اذربيجان وارمينيا هذا ما يقوله المسؤولون
في باكو اذ يطفئون نيران صراع كرباخ لكن
ما ترغب به باكو وما قد تضطر اليه ريفان
خاضع لا محاله لحسابات ومصالح حلفاء
الطرفين وعليه يدخل خلاف البلدين حلبه
صراع النفوذ بين روسيا والغرب تشترك ايران
في حدود مع اذربيجان وارمينيا تجد طهران
نفسها اكثر المعنيين بكل ما يحدث في
جارتيها السوفيتيتين السابقتين يجري
الرئيس الايراني ابراهيم رئيس محادثات مع
نظيره الروسي فلاديمير بوتين فروسيا هي
الوسيط التاريخي بين ارمينيا واذربيجان
خلال ثلاثين عاما من الحرب في اقليم كرباخ
في المقابل يتوافد المسؤولون الغربيون على
الحدود بين البلدين تصل ثمان سباور معلنه
عن دعم مالي امريكي لسكان كاراباخ من
الاقليم الذي اصبح فعليا جزءا من اراضي
اذربيجان وفي بروكسل يلتقي المسؤولون
الاذربيجانيون والارمينيون لبحث تطبيع
العلاقات بين باكو وريفان تجري اللقاءات
بواسطه الاتحاد الاوروبي وبدعم واشنطن
وبمباركه تركيا حاليا في اذربيجان الاقرب
والحقيقه ان مصالح كبيره قد تدفع لتطبيع
العلاقات بين الجارتين اللدودتين تسعى
اذربيجان الى الحصول على موافقه ارمينيا
لاقامه خط زينجازور للسكك الحديديه لاعاده
اتصال اذربيجان باقليم ناخشيفان ثم الى
الاراضي التركيه والفضاء الاوروبي من
ورائها بدورها تصر الحكومه الارمينيه على
ضمان اذربيجان لحقوق ارمن كاراباخ خاصه
الحقوق الثقافيه واللغه الارمينيه وسهوله
تنقلهم عبر الحدود الغاز لربما هو كلمه سر
في حسم صراع كرباخ فليذر بيجان مصلحه
لانهاء الصراع الطويل الامد للتفرغ
لمشاريع ربط الطاقه بين البلدين فما ان
حسم صراع الكهرباء حتى وضع الرئيسان
التركي والاذر بجنيه حجر الاساس لخط
وقد ابدت الدول الغربيه حرصا على علاقات
جيده مع اذربيجان التي اصبحت الان مركزا
مهما لتصدير الطاقه الى اوروبا في ظل
مساعي بروكسل الى تنويع مصادر الطاقه
بعيدا عن روسيا ينقل الغاز من اذربيجان
الى اوروبا من خلال خط تناب العابر
الاناضول والذي يربط حقول الغاز
الاذربيجانيه في بحر قزوين بجورجيا وتركيا
ومن ثم الى الاتحاد الاوروبي وكذلك خط غاز
تاب الذي ينقل الغاز الاذربيجاني الى
اوروبا عبر البحر الادرياتيكي اما ارمينيا
فهي معنيه بفتح بوابه لها نحو الاتحاد
الاوروبي عبر تركيا من خلال اعاده فتح
المعابر الحدوديه بين البلدين خطوه ستحدث
ان طبعت العلاقات بين باكو وريفان تتطلع
ارمينيا ايضا لان تحلق طائراتها عبر
الاجواء التركيه وتطمح باذن من انقره يتيح
لشركه الطيران الارمنيه تشغيل رحلات الى
اوروبا عبر المجال الجوي التركي
[موسيقى]
مساء الخير الزين بالفعل هي مستمره
وكثيفه هناك طوابير
كيلومترات من السيارات على طريق ممر
لاتشين وصولا الى غوريس كما ذكرنا اخر
احصائيه وردت هي 28 الف لكن اتوقع ان
العدد الان تجاوز الثلاثين الف لان هذه
الحركه مستمره وهذه السيارات يعني هي في
طابورها الطويل منذ يومين تقريبا وفقا لما
وردنا من مصادر محليه زين مدن داخل اقليم
كهربا الان قد فرغت بالكامل نتحدث عن
مارتوني وعن مارتاكرت وعن هذه المدن
تقريبا لم يبقى فيها احد من ارمن كارباخ
من تبقى حتى الان هم موجودون في ستيفانا
كيرت عاصمه الاقليم وفيما حولها وطبعا بعد
مئه عام من الحكم الذاتي يرفض الارمن
اليوم ان يكون
تابعين لاذربيجان نحن نعلم ان هذه المنطقه
اقليم كاراباخ كانت خاضعه للحكم الذاتي
زمن الاتحاد السوفيتي مع قرب انهيار
الاتحاد السوفيتي حاولت ان تعلن استقلالها
وبالتالي الغت اذربيجان هذا الحكم الذاتي
القائم واعلنت الحرب وبدات حرب ست سنوات
انتهت الى سيطره الارمن على تلك الاراضي
داخل اذربيجان على اقليم كاراباخ والان
بعد حرب اخرى و30 عاما من الحروب حقيقه
يبدو ان الثقه معدومه يبدو ان السكان
يفضلون المغادره على ان يبقوا تحت
اذربيجان من ناحيه اخرى كان هناك اليوم
واحد من الاحداث البارزه هو ارتفاع حصيله
الضحايا الذين عرفوا جراء انفجار استبانا
كارد خزان الوقود فيها هناك بينما كان
الناس يتزودون بالوقوف الرحيل
ارتفع هذا العدد الى 68
نعم مشهوره شكرا جزيلا محمود الزئبق من
الحدود الاذربيجانيه الارمنيه
كما ذكر محمود ارتفع عدد ضحايا انفجار
مستودع للوقود في مدينه ستباني كارت
هي عاصمه اقليم كهرباء الى سبعه وستين
وقالت وزاره الصحه في المنطقه الواقعه في
جنوب القوقاز ان مئه وثمانيه وستين شخصا
اصيب جراء الانفجار واصابه بعضهم خطيره
للغايه وقد نقلوا الى المستشفى في العاصمه
الارمنيه يرفان بينهم 96 نقلوا بواسطه
مروحيات ارمينيه وروسيه ولكن لم يتضح حتى
الان سببه هذا الانفجار
[موسيقى]
الى ملف اخر توعدت موسكو على لسان المتحدث
باسم الكربلندمتري بسكوف بحرق دبابات التي
تسلبتها من الولايات المتحده بينما حذر
نائب رئيس مجلس الامن القوميه الروسيه من
اندلاعي صراعي مباشر مع الغرب وجاء
التهديد في يوم حافر بالهجمات والهجمات
المضاده في اوكرانيا اذ الحق القصف الروسي
بالمسيرات اضرارا كبيره بمدينه اسماعيل
بيوديسه الذي تستخدمه اوكرانيا في الشهور
الاخيره لتصدير الحبوب
الحرب التي لا تعرف استراحه لا ليلى ولا
نهارا لا في السماء ولا على اليابسه
والبحر لما الرعب خلال القصف الروسي
بصواريخ ومسيرات على ميناء اسماعيل المطل
على نهر الدانوب باوديسا ساعتين من هنا
كانت تصدر الحبوب الى الخارج بعد انسحاب
موسكو من اتفاق تعذرت تمديده اذ وصلت
المفاوضات الى طريق مسدود اعتراض القوات
الاوكرانيه لمعظم المسيرات المشاركه في
الهجوم وفق روايتها لم يمنع تفاديا الحاق
اضرار كبيره بالميناء والمستودعات وحجز
التفتيش لم يتاخر ردوا كييف التي قصفت
محطه كهرباء فرعيه في منطقه كورسك الروسيه
تحدث حاكم المنطقه الحدوديه عن انقطاع
الكهرباء عن سبع بلدات جراء الهجوم من
جهته اعلن الحاكم الروسي لمدينه سيفا
ستوبول احباط هجوم صاروخي قرب مطار
حرب المسيرات المتبادله بين المتقاتلين في
الصراع تقابلها شبهه مشتعله يزعم كل طرف
انه يحقق تقدما فيها تراهن وتتفاءل كياف
بترشيح الكفه لصالحها بعد وصولي اول دفعه
من دبابات ابرامز الامريكيه التي طال
انتظارها والموعود رسميا منذ يناير الماضي
لم يفوت
الرئيسكي الفرصه ليلقي كلمه ترحيبا
بالدبابات التي بحث صوته وهو يطالب بها مع
منظومه صواريخ اتاكمز لا تفرح كثيرا رد
عليه اكثر من مسؤول روسي بعد هذا الخطاب
توعد المتحدث باسم الكرملين
انه لا يوجد علاج سحري ولا سلاح يمكنه
تغيير ميزان القوه في ساحه المعركه
تعاهدت واشنطن بتزويد كييف باحدى وثلاثين
مزوده بذخائره تحتوي على اليورانيوم
المنظم بعيار 120 ملم ذخيره مثيره للجدل
بسبب مخاطرها السامه على الجيش والمدنيين
بنبره حاده انتقد مجددا نائب رئيس مجلس
الامن الروسي
تدفق السلاح الغربي الثقيل على اوكرانيا
هدد بان الخيارات امام روسيا
تتضاءلوا ومنها خيار المواجهه المباشره مع
النيتو الذي تحول الى كتله فاشيه شبيهه
بمحور هتلر على حد تعبيره نتائج محاور
المعارك المباشره او غير المباشره في هذا
الصراع اما غير ثابته او غير واضحه في حرب
الكل يخرج فيها ما بقي من اوراق وسلاح
وعتاد بحثا عن حسم مفقود ولا يبدو قريبا
تكلفه الحرب الانسانيه قبل الماديه على
الجميع باهظه ومؤلمه
وبخسائر قد تستمر عقودا طوال
عيسى الاوكرانيه في ان قوات بلاده دمرت
الخدمات اللوجستيه ومقرات القوات الروسيه
في شرق وجنوب البلاد واكد زلينسكي في كلمه
المتلفزه ان حكومته تبحث عن شركاء جدد
لامدادات الذخيره واصفا العقوبات على
روسيا بغير الكافيه
العقوبات ليست كافيه سيكون هناك المزيد من
اجراءاتنا ضد الدوله الارهابيه طالما
العدوان الروسي مستمر فيجب ان تشعر روسيا
بالخسائر
[موسيقى]
الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجيه اهلا وسهلا
بك
بالنسبه لتصريحات
فيما يتعلق بانه لا يوجد سلاح يمكن ان
يغير موازين القوه في المعركه
روسيا لديها كل الاسلحه ولم تغير بالفعل
موازين القوى في المعركه لكن مع دخول
دبابات واحتمال وصول طائرات اف 16 الا تظن
ان هذا سيغير الموازين
وصول الدبابات عبر رمز المتطوره
اي ابرز ام واحد هذا لن يغير اي شيء لان
الهجمات المضاده الاوكرانيه فشلت وهذا ما
يعترف به خبراء روسيا وخبراء البنتاجون
وفي اوروبا الجامعيين جميع متفقين على انه
ليس هناك اسلحه اعجازيه ممكن ان تؤثر على
مجرى المعارك لان روسيا تدمر هؤلاء
الدبابات وخبرائها وكل المعدات بل هذه
المعدات تشتعل ولدينا تفوق في السماء
والحديث الان ليس عن
المروحيات وانظمه الدفاع الجوي
والطائرات المقاتله التي تدمر مختلف
المعدات وهذا ما سيحدث لابرهم لان كل نقاط
ضعف هذه الدببه معروفه بالنسبه لنا
كل الاجزاء الضعيفه فيها سوف نقوم
باصابتها بالصواريخ المضاده للدبابات وسوف
تشتعل كما اشتعل تشالنجر وغيرها من
المعدات فيما يتعلق بشبه جزيره القرم في
موسكو كيف تقراون استمرار وتكثيف الهجمات
الاوكرانيه على شبه جزيره القرم
و
منظومات الدفاع الجوي في القرن تسقط تسقط
حوالي 90% من المسيرات
والصواريخ التي تتوجه للقرم ومختلف مدنيها
حوالي 30 مسيره يوميا وانا كنت في احدى
الايام عندما كانت تجري هذه الهجمات ورايت
انظمه الدفاع
الجوي
وسطه قريبه المدى او بعيده المدى وكانت
تسقط هذه المسيرات بالنسبه للصواريخ بعيده
المدى ومتوسطه المدى المدى الفرنسيه
والبريطانيه التي تستخدمها القوات
الاوكرانيه هذه صواريخ ثقيله كل صاروخ
حوالي طن و300 كيلو جرام تستخدم من مراكز
جويه اي المقاتلات او من منصات ارضيه
هم ليس لديهم مقاتلات مناسبه لهذه
الصواريخ واستخدامها ولكن المنصات الارضيه
موجوده وقدمت من فرنسا كل هذه المعدات دون
الدعم الغربي والامريكي هو شيء ما كان
يحدث لولا الدعم بالمعلومات وبالاسلحه من
الدول الغربيه وتحصل اوكرانيا على معلومات
من الاقمار الصناعيه ومن مسيرات الاستكشاف
التي
تحلق تحلق على البحر الاسود ينظم واشنطن
لاريكورد مساعد وزير الدفاع الامريكيه
السابق وكبير الباحثين في مركز خدمه
الى جزء مما قاله ضيفنا لكن كنا نسال عن
تصريحات ان كل المعدات الغربيه لن تحدث
فرقا في المعركه هل توافق
كلا لا اوافق ابدا بشكل اساسي ان الدعم
الغربي استمر لفتره طويله اكثر مما ظنته
روسيا والدعم يتقدم اكثر فاكثر الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه في البدايه لم تود ان
تقدم الدبابات ولكنها غيرت في موقفها
والاوكرانيون يحصلون على الاسلحه المتقدمه
والاوكرانيون استحواذ على 15% من الاراضي
التي كان الروس قد سيطروا عليها في
البدايه
وحوالي ربع مليون جنديه روسيه قتل او جرح
في هذه المعركه والدعم الغربي طبعا لانه
في الغرب هناك ديمقراطيات هناك وجهات نظر
متعدده ومختلفه ولكن معظم الدول في حلف
شمال الاطلسي على استعدادا لدعم
الاوكرانيين حتى النهايه لانهم يرون ان
تبعات النصر الروسي يؤثر او تؤثر سلبا على
مستقبل العالم واوروبا ايضا يبدو ان هنالك
عدم ارتياح اوكراني من الدعم الغربي انه
ليس كافيا الرئيس يقول ان العقوبات غير
كافيه يقول ايضا انه يبحث عن مصادر بديله
للذخيره لماذا يحتاج الى مصادر بديله
للذخيره اذا كانت دعم الغربي بهذه القوه
الحقيقه وبشكل اساسي الدول الغربيه وحتى
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه نفذت منها
الذخيره ولذلك نسرع في عمليه انتاج هذه
الذخيره ونقدمها للاوكرانيين مباشره من
المصانع بعدما تصنع بشكل مباشر وطبعا
الاوكرانيون دائم دائما ما ارادوا اكثر
الرئيس بايدن تنبه في الخطوات اذا قدم
الدعم
لاوكرانيا ولكن من دون استفزازي الروس
باتجاه استخدام الاسلحه النوويه وهي مخاوف
لدى فرنسا لدى المملكه المتحده لدى
الولايات المتحده وهي كلها دول نوويه وما
من احد يود مواجهه النوويه ولذلك واشنطن
تقدم الاسلحه بشكل تدريجي اخذه بعين
الاعتبار ضروره تحقيق الاهداف من الجانب
الاوكراني هل من ضمن هذه الاهداف هي
استعادت كل الاراضي الاوكرانيه بما في ذلك
شبه جزيره القرم واذا كان هذا هدف حقيقي
ما المطلوب لتحقيقه وما المدى الزمني
لتحقيقه
النقطه الاساسيه بالنسبه الى الاوكرانيين
هي السيطره على شبه جزيره القرم ولكن اذا
ما اراد الروس ان يتفاوضوا الى بشان الوضع
الذي كان قبل بدايه الحرب لربما الغرب
يدعم مسار التفاوض طبعا اوكرانيا لن تقول
انها تتراجع بشكل علني في موقفها ولكن اذا
ما بدات المفاوضات لربما هذه نقطه يمكن
تناقش بشانها ولكن الاوكرانيين لم يظهروا
اي اشارات بانهم على استعدادا للتخلي عن
شبه جزيره القرم وهم في طور تحصين قدراتهم
العسكريه وهنا في هذا الاسبوع قاموا
بعمليات اساسيه
واثبت ان الروس يتعرضون للضرر الكبير
وخصوصا في شبه جزيره القرم شكرا جزيلا لك
مساعد وزير الدفاع الامريكي السابق وكبير
الباحثين في مركز التقدم الامريكي ضيفنا
من واشنطن
اذا الكريم الدبابات وصواريخ اتاكنز
الامريكيه لن تغير الوضع في ساحه القتال
وكان مسؤولون امريكيون قالوا الاسبوع
الماضي ان الرئيس جو بايدن ابلغ نظيره
الاوكراني
ان واشنطن ستقدم عرضا محدودا من صواريخ
اتكانز وهي ارض ارض بعيده المدى للمساعده
في الحرب مع روسيا في التقرير التالي
الزميل زاهر علي يستعرض اهميه الصواريخ
وقدرتها العسكريه
تعرف بانها صواريخ باليستيه بعيده المدى
موجهه وشديده الدقه يصل مداها الى نحو 300
كم ويمكن اطلاقها من منصات متحركه كراجمات
الصواريخ هاي مارس هذا الصاروخ مصمم
لمهاجمه الاهداف الاستراتيجيه كالمطارات
ومواقع صواريخ ارض جو وقوات المدفعيه
ومناطق الامداد ومجموعات القياده او نقاط
الاتصالات اما عن حركته الجويه فان ارتفاع
صاروخ التكامز يتراوح من 50 الى 65 كيلو
مترا ويسمح هذا الارتفاع للصاروخ بتجنب
معظم انظمه الدفاع ارض جو مع الحفاظ على
الدقه اللازمه للضربات
اما عن سرعته فتصلوا الى حوالي ثلاثه الاف
وسبعمائه كيلو متر في الساعه ويبلغ طوله
اربعه امتار ووزن راسه الحربي بين 160
و560 كيلو جراما اضافه الى ان تصميم
الصاروخ الذي يعمل بالوقود الصلب يجعله
مناسبا للعمل في بيئات متنوعه
وتعتمد صواريخ اتكامز على راس حربي ينشا
عنه انفجار تعادل شدته القوه التفجيريه
لنحو 28
كيلو جراما من ماده تي ان تي وتوجه عن
طريق الملاحه وبمساعده نظام تحديد المواقع
جي بي اس
هذا الصاروخ موجود لدى القوات البريه
الامريكيه منذ عام
1990 واطلق منه
450 صاروخا خلال غزو العراق عام
2003 وفيما بعد عام 2015 اطلق اكثر من 500
وستين صاروخا من نظام التكانز في حروب عده
[موسيقى]
قال المتحدث باسم الخارجات الامريكيه
ماثيو ميلر ان الحوار اليمنيه اليمني هو
الوحيد القادر على انهاء الحرب والازمه
الانسانيه في اليمن
على الحدود السعوديه اليمنيه وادى الى
مقتل جنديين بحرينيين واصابه اخرين نقف مع
مملكه البحرين شريكنا الاستراتيجي طويل
الامد ونقدم خالصه تعازينا للحكومه واوسر
الضحايا ونتمنى للمصابين التعافي وقد اكد
الوزير بلينكين في لقاءاته خلال اجتماعات
الامم المتحده على ان الاتفاق السياسي
اليمني اليمني هو وحده القادر على حل
الصراع بشكل دائم وانهاء الازمه الانسانيه
ونحن نكرر هذه الدعوه اليوم
وينضم الينا من الخارجات الامريكيه
التيموسي
المبعوث الامريكي الخاص الى اليمن سيدن
كنج اهلا وسهلا بك الولايات المتحده تسعى
عبر زيارتكم المتكرره الى تحقيق السلام
دائم وشامل في اليمن وفق التعبير الامريكي
عبر حوار اليمني يمني ماذا اثمرت هذه
الجهود حتى الان
اعيد السؤال عليكم مره اخرى
ستمثل المبعوث الامريكي الخاص الى اليمن
سؤال هو الموقف الامريكي واضح فيما يتعلق
باليمن تحقيق سلام دائم وشامل عبر حوار
يمني يمني وقد سعت الولايات المتحده لذلك
عبر كثير من الزيارات منها زيارتكم
المتكرره الى المنطقه سؤالي هو ماذا اثمرت
هذه الجهود حتى هذه اللحظه
هل تسمعني سيد تمثيل
مشكله في الصوت مع السيد التماثيل
المبعوث الامريكي الخاص الى اليمن كان
معنا من مقر الخارجيه
الامريكيه في واشنطن
محاليل الجزيره من الجيش السودانيه شنا
سلسله غارات بالطائرات المسيره استهدفت
مواقع قوات الدعم السريع في عرض من
الاحياء الشرق النيل وفي غضون ذلك ذكرت
مصادر محليه ان قوات الدعم السريع اطلقت
الرصاص بكثافه لساعات من اسلحه المضادات
الارضيه التابعه لها ويتزامن ذلك مع
اشتداد الازمه الاقتصاديه في السودان في
ظل الزياره اعداد النازح
السودان لم يهدا بعد المعارك مستمره دون
مؤشر على قرب نهايتها على الارض استهدف
الجيش السوداني مواقع لقوات الدعم السريع
وبغارات بالطائرات المسيره في عدد من
الاحياء شرق النيل من بينها الجريف شرقي
العاصمه والمدينه الرياضيه وحي المجاهدين
جنوبي الخرطوم كما قصف الجيش بالمدفعيه
اهدافا لقوات الدعم السريع وسط غربي مدينه
ام درمان والخرطوم بحري تزامنا مع هذه
الغارات تحدثت مصادر محليه عن اطلاق قوات
الدعم السريع للرصاص بالكثافه ولساعات من
اسلحه المضادات الارضيه التابعه لها ليس
بعيدا عن ساحه المعركه يتم تمديد حاله
الطوارئ لمده شهر بولايه الجزيره المتاخمه
للعاصمه الخرطوم من الجنوب وهي الولايه
التي تستضيف مئات الالاف من الفارينه من
الحرب رغم تمركز قوه الدعم السريع في
شمالها حيث يصنف هذا الجزء من الولايه
منطقه عمليات الحربيه بين ضباب الدخان
المتصاعد من لهب المعارك يختنق الاف
السودانيين بالتداعيات الاقتصاديه لهذه
الحرب ملايين النازحين في السودان وعددهم
الاعلى الان في العالم يكافحون من اجل
البقاء البعض منهم يعود الى العاصمه باحثا
عن لقمه عيش رغم الاقتتال في ظل الارتفاع
اسعارها في مناطق اخرى سواء العائدون الى
العاصمه او الذين لم يعودوا اليها الكل
يواجه سوق عمل مشلوله تزيد الوضع هشاشه
الوضع الذي يئن تحت ظروف سوء التغذيه
والتغير المناخي والصعوبه وصول المساعدات
ارقام الامم المتحده تؤكد نزوح اكثر من
خمسه ملايين نسمه من سكان السودان منذ
اندلاع القتال انتقل اكثر من مليون منهم
الى البلدان المجاوره ومن تبقوا في
السودان فيرزحون تحت ركود اقتصادي خانق
تغذيه الحرب كل ثانيه
من جديد نعد الى تمثيل من مقر الخارجيه
الامريكيه المبعوثه الامريكيه الخاص الى
اليمن وكنت اسالك سيد
ما الذي اثمرت عنه الجهود الامريكيه حتى
الان لتحقيق ما تقول الولايات المتحده انه
سلام دائم وشامل عبر حوار يمني يمني
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
ركزت ومنذ اليوم الاول من هذه الاداره على
تحقيق اتفاق سلاما شاملا في اليمن بجمع
اطراف النزاع بقياده الامم المتحده وهناك
تقدم جيد احرزه في هذا الملف في السنه
ونصف الماضيه خفض التصعيد باستثناء ما حصل
يوم امس الحادث المؤسف اذا خفض التصعيد
وفتح مطار الصنعه للطائرات التجاريه
ونزع العراقي المرتبطه بايصال النفط
والمعدات وتبادل السجناء في ابريل اعتقد
ان كل هذه النقاط هي ايجابيه ووفد الحوثي
زارا الرياض الاسبوع الماضي وكان هناك
مباحثات ايجابيه كل ذلك نقاط مهمه ولذلك
هذه اللحظه فيها امل ويتعين علينا ان نضيع
قدما في هذه الجهود نعم على ما ينصب
تركيزكم الان ما الذي تسعون لتحقيقه في
هذه اللحظه لحظه الامل هذه
التركيز بالنسبه الى جهود الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه هو الوصول الى عمليه
السلام يمنيه بقياده من الامم المتحده تصل
الى وقف دائم لاطلاق النار بناء على
الهدنه التي كانت منذ 18 شهرا وجمع
اليمنيين للمناقشه وللحوار بشان مستقبل
بلادهم وسحب القوات الاجنبيه باستثناء
التي تتفق عليها القيادات اليمنيه او
لمكافحه المجموعات الارهابيه في اليمن
ولكن اجتماع اليمنيين من اجل تقرير مستقبل
البلاد هذا هو هدف الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه منذ ان تم تعيين مبعوثا لهذه
الاداره الامريكيه
ما هي الصيغه التي يمكن ان يجتمع بها
اليمنيون معا العبرا حوار اقليمي عبر
اطراف اقليميه ام كيف
اعتقد ان هناك بعض الخيرات المهمه الذي
حصل بين اطراف النزاع اذا ما عينا
الاجتماعات التي تمت على مستوى اللجان
العسكريه وتبادل السجناء ما كان ليحصل لو
لم يتم الاتفاق المضي قدما بين الاطراف
بالاضافه الى مليون
برميل من حامله او ناقله سافر الذي حصل في
يوليو وتم تفريغه من حامله او ناقله النفط
اذا هذا كله نتيجه الاتفاق ولذلك هناك
رغبه لوصولي الى اتفاق سلام هناك بعض
التفاصيل التي يجب العمل عليها ولكن هناك
انخراط
السعوديه في صنعاء والبعثه الحوثيه في
الرياض الاسبوع الماضي كلها تشير الى جهود
حقيقيه ونحن بحاجه الى دول الاقليميه لكي
تدعم هذه الجهود
فيما يتعلق بالعقبات ما هي العقبات الان
ما الذي يمنع الوصول الى هذا السلام الداء
الشامل
والدائم وفق المفهوم الامريكي
اعتقد انه يمكننا ان نعاين حقيقه التحديات
الاقتصاديه في اليمن التي كانت قائمه حتى
قبل بدايه هذا النزاع والتي لا تزال قائمه
بالنسبه الى كيفيه توزيع الموارد اليمنيه
والتاكد من الامن الغذائي في البلاد هذه
امور صعبه للغايه بالنسبه الى اليمنيين
لكي يتفقوا عليها اعتقد ان هناك نقص كبير
في الثقه وتراكم هذا النقص في الثقه مع
سنوات النزاع كان هناك دمار حصل على مستوى
البنى التحتيه هناك عراقيل تعيق وصول
المساعدات والسلع الانسانيه كل هذه الامور
يجب ان تحل الان واعتقد ان السبيل للقيام
بذلك وفقا لما تراه الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه والمجتمع الدولي وذلك من خلال
عمليه يمنيه يمنيه برعايه امميه يمكننا ان
نصل الى هذه المرحله وهناك تحرك ايجابي
بهذا الاتجاه يجب ان استفيد منه هل ما حدث
من
هجوم استهدف قوات بحرينيه على الحدود مع
السعوديه
له تاثير سلبي على هذه الاجواء التي تقول
انها اجواء غير مسبوقه
لا يمكننا ان نفهم انه بعد خمسه ايام من
مغادراتي الوفد الحوثي من المملكه العربيه
السعوديه في بيئه بدات ايجابيه وتعاونيه
لا نفهم هذا الهجوم الفظيع الذي ادى الى
مقتل جنديين شابين بحريين بحرينيين ونحن
نتحدث عن لحظه حزينه الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه تضم صوتها الى العديدين الذين
دانوا هذا الهجوم دول الخليج ودول الاقليم
كلها دانت هذا الهجوم وهو لا ينسجم مع
روحيه وتركيز الترتيبات المرتبطه بالسلام
هو يوم حزين عندما نرى سقوط اي ضحايا في
اليمن ولكنها تحدثوا عن حادث مؤسف للغايه
على وجه الخصوص ولكننا نركز على المضي
قدما ونعمل مع الفرقه
لتعزيز الجهود الحوار اليمني اليمني بين
الفرقاء وهذا ممكن للغايه ما هي رسالتكم
للاطراف الاقليميه نعلم ان الولايات
المتحده تتبنى منهج حوار يمني يمني لكن
هذه القضيه ليست يمنيه يمنيه فقط هنالك
اطراف اقليميه ما هي رسالتكم للاطراف
الاقليميه الان
رسالتي الى الاطراف الاقليميه هي بضروره
انتهازي هذه الفرصه هذه اللحظه والاستفاده
من التقدم المحرز لمساعده اطراف النزاع
لانضمام في عمليه تفوضيه بشان مستقبل
اليمن من دوني محاوله املائي مستقبل اليمن
عليهم لنضع اليمنيين يتخذون هذا القرار
ومع توافق الاراء على المستوى الاقليمي
والذي رايناه وانخراط ايجابي للغايه من
قبل العماليين مؤخرا هذا هو نوع العمل
الذي براينا يمكن ان يساعد بشكل كبير في
جمع الاطراف دعونا نركز على ذلك الخطوه
تلو الاخرى ننتقل للمضي قدما بدعم
اليمنيين وحوار اليمني من اجل استعاده
اليمنيين لبلادهم واعادت بنائها اشكرك
شكرا جزيلا من مقر الخارجيه الامريكيه في
واشنطن تمثل
المبعوث الامريكي الخاص لليمن
[موسيقى]
محفل عسكري واسع النطاق في العاصمه
الهنديه قاده جيوش 30 دوله يلتقون في
نيودلهي في مقدمتهم رئيس الاركان الامريكي
الجديد راندي جورج ونظيره الهندي مع
نوجباندي يبحث الاجتماع التهديدات التي
تواجه منطقه اسيا والمحيط الهادئ على وقع
تصاعد سعي الصين لتعزيز نفوذها هناك
هذه المنطقه ذات اهميه بالغه بالنسبه لنا
واعتقد انكم رايتم ذلك من خلال استراتيجيه
الدفاعيه الوطنيه هذه اولويه وجيشنا منتشر
في جميع انحاء العالم لكننا لتلك الاهميه
نجري تدريبات هنا اكثر من اي مكان اخر في
المحيط الهادئ تعهد جورج ايضا بالحفاظ على
منطقه المحيطين الهندي والهادئ حره
ومفتوحه قائد جيش الهند الدوله المضيفه
مانوج بانتي اكد من جانبه الاجتماع
والتدريبات العسكريه المرتقبه ليست موجهه
ضد احد الا ان استضافه الهند للاجتماع
وانخراطها في تعاون عسكري وثيق مع
الولايات المتحده لا يلغي خصوصيه موقفها
كحليف تقليدي لموسكو ولعلها بالتقارب مع
واشنطن ربما تسعى لمسك العصا من المنتصف
تترقب الصين بالمقابل اجتماعات وانشطه
عسكريه مماثله بكثير من التحفظ فوزير
خارجيتها
ستعارض ما وصفه بانه توسع متهور للتحالفات
العسكريه
صداع التحالفات العسكريه الغربيه يزعج
الصين بشكل مزمن وطالما حذرت من عواقب اي
مسعا لانشاء ما تعتبره تحالفا عسكريا على
غرار النيتو في منطقه اسيا والمحيط الهادئ
وحراك واشنطن في هذا السياق لا يخفى ففي
اغسطس الماضي استقبل الرئيس الامريكي
نظيره الكوري الجنوبي ورئيس وزراء في قمه
تتجاوز حساسيات التاريخ بين جارتي الصين
وترمي لتعزيز التعاون العسكري في مواجهه
بيجينغ ليس ذلك فقط فثمت تحالفات حديثه
الانشاء مثل اوكوس ويضم الولايات المتحده
والمملكه المتحده واستراليا واقيم في
سبتمبر 2021 ضمن توجه امريكي بجعل اسيا
منطقه ذات اولويه استراتيجيه قصوى هناك
ايضا تحالف [__] ويضم الولايات المتحده
واليابان والهند واستراليا اعلن قيامه عام
2007 واعيد احيائه بعد انتخاب الرئيس
الامريكي جو بايدن اواخر 2021
تحالفات تترقبها الصين بريبه ومحاولات
مضاده تبقي منطقه المحيطين الهندي والهادئ
بؤره التوتر واهتمام لا ينقطعان
وفي سياق التوتر في شرق اسيا ايضا انهت
وحدات من رابطه اسيان اول تدريبات عسكريه
مشتركه لها على الاطلاق في بحر لاتون
الشمالي باندونيسيا وتاتي هذه التدريبات
وسط توترات بين عدد من الدول الكبرى
واحتجاجات ضد انشطه الصين في بحر جنوب
الصين ويعد بحر ناتونه الشمالي احد اهم
الممرات العالميه للسفن التجاريه
والعسكريه بين المحيط الهادئ وشمالي شرق
اسيا كما يعد مصدرا لثروات سمكيه هائله
انه بحر اتون الشمالي الذي يقع الى الجنوب
من بحر جنوب الصين ليست اندونيسيا غافله
عن اهميته في ظل تنافس صيني امريكي على
بسط النفوذ في شرق اسيا
قطرها 1000 كيلومتر تشمل كوالالمبور
وسنغافوره وهو برونايدر السلام وعندما
نوسع الدائره بقطر 2000 كيلومتر فكل عواصم
دول اسيان تدخل في تلك الدائره ومن ثم
اهميتها الجيو استراتيجيه
نحو 60 الف سفينه تمر ببحر جنوب الصين
الواصل بين شرق اسيا والمحيط الهندي نسبه
كبيره منها تتخذه ممر نحو بحر ناتونه وهو
اقرب الممرات واقلها كلفه لمن يبحر باتجاه
الشرق الاوسط واوروبا او ياتي منهما
بحر ناتونا فيه كثير من الثروات الطبيعيه
وهو منطقه مهمه لدول عده لذا من المحتمل
ان يكون لاي دوله لها حدود مع هذه المنطقه
طموح في الاستكشاف والتنقيب عن ثرواتها
لهذا نريد التاكيد من جانبنا على اهميه
موقعنا
وهذا سبب وجيه يدفع اندونيسيا الى تنظيم
مناورات عسكريه في بحر ناتونا واخرها مع
جيرانها من دول اسيا لاسيما اثر تكرار نشر
الصين خريطه تزعم فيها سيادتها على مياه
بحر جنوب الصين المحاذيه لبحر ناتونا
في ظل توتر يتصاعد في جنوب شرق اسيا
وتجاذب مزاعم السياده على المياه والجزر
في بحر جنوب الصين او بالقرب منه تسعى
اندونيسيا ودول اسيان الى ترسيخ حضورها في
مياهها وجزرها الاقليميه كبحرناتون
الشمالي في الاهميه الاستراتيجيه
والاقتصاديه والملاحيه
المسؤولون المحليون في جزر ناتونا يطالبون
بجعل جزرهم منطقه اقتصاديه خاصه واعانه
الصيادين وحمايتهم
ما نحتاج اليه نحن الصيادين هو الشعور
بالامن لان موقع ناتونا حدودي مع دول
كثيره لذلك فان صيادي تلك الدول يتسللون
الى بحارنا فنشعر اننا مهددون خصوصا خلال
السنوات الثلاث الماضيه حيث تزايدت اعداد
سفن الصيد الاجنبيه في بحر ناتون الشمالي
كما يطالب الصيادون بملاحقه السفن الصيد
الاجنبيه واغراقها وهي سياسه كانت متبعه
سابقا لسنوات وساعدت الصيادين المحليين
على مضاعفه ما يصيدونه وتصديره حيث يوجد
في بحر ناتونا نحو ربع الثروه السمكيه في
البلاد
صهيب جاسم الجزيره بحرنا تونه شماليه
اندونيسيا
هي اخبرنا الاخرى الطاقه الذريه الايرانيه
محمد اسلامي ان بلاده تتعارض بشكل جيد مع
الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه الذريه اوضح في
تصريحه للجزيره ان نحو 120 مفتشا من
الوكاله معتمدون حاليا لدى طيران
في هذا الوقت اكثر من 120 مفتشا مقبولون
ومعتمدون لدى ايران وهم يعملون فعليا واذا
كنا نرفض عدد القليل منهم فهذا حقنا فنحن
نراقب تصرفاتهم ومن حقنا قبول او رفض اي
منهم وقرار عدم قبول بعضهم لا يعني ان
ايران لا تتعاون بل نحن نتعاون مع الوكاله
وهذا التعاون نسقه يومي متواصل ولكن بسبب
تصرف بعض المفتشين رفضوا وهذا عدي ومعمول
به
كما هكذا محمد اسلامي ضروره توقف الضغوط
السياسيه التي تمارس على بلاده اعتبر في
تصريح الجزيره عده قضايا تلام عليها ايران
هي ناجمه في الواقع عن معلومات المزيفه
ومختلقه من قبل اعدائها وفق تعبيرها
نتمنى ان تتوقف الضغوط والتاثيرات
السياسيه التي مورست علينا خلال السنوات
العشرين الماضيه بل يجب ان تتوقف لان ما
يلوموننا عليه مزيف وهي معلومات مختلقه من
قبل اعدائنا كل انشطتنا مبنيه على نظام
الضمانات وسنواصل عملنا فبرنامجنا معلوم
على الصعيد الدولي فهم يعلمون اهدافنا
ويعلمون بوضوح تفاصيل ما تفعله ايران في
كل منشاتها من خلال ما نقدمه من تفاصيله
وتوضيحات للوكاله
واشدد رئيس هيئه الطاقه الذريه الايرانيه
على تعاون الطيران المتواصل مع الوكاله
الدوليه للطاقه الذريه واضاف في تصريحها
للجزيره ان ايران تخضع للتفتيش اكثر بعشره
اضعاف من اي دوله اخرى حسب وصفه
لقائي مع السيد جروسي كان لقاء صداقه وفي
مناخ عادي لان تعاوننا مع الوكاله اهم من
تعاون اي بلد اخر معها نواجه اكبر تفتيش
ممكن لمنشاتنا يوميا واذا ما اردنا تحديد
حجم منشاتنا فهي تمثل نحو اثنين في المئه
من المنشات النوويه حول العالم وعمليات
التفتيش التي تنفذها الوكاله في ايران
تقدر بنحو 25% من تلك التي تنفذها حول
العالم غير معقول ان يتم تفتيشنا اكثر من
الدول الاخرى 10 مرات
الى الاراضي الفلسطينيه وقال الجيش
الاسرائيلي انه هاجم نقطه عسكريه تابعه
لحركه حماس في منطقه رفح بجنوبي قطاع غزه
بطائره مسيره وبثت وسائل الاعلام
الاسرائيليه مشاهد الاندلاع حرائق في
مستوطنات غلاف غزه بعد اطلاق دفعات من
البالونات الحارقه من القطع وبحسب الاعلام
الاسرائيلي فان فلسطينيين تسللوا الى
المنطقه الحدوديه واحرقوا موقعا عسكريا
في غضون ذلك اعلنت وزاره الصحه بغزه اصابه
احد عشر فلسطينيين بجروح مختلفه جراء قمع
قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي مظاهرات القربى
الشريط الحدودي الشرقيه القطع واطلقت قوات
الاحتلال الرصاصه والغاز المسيره للدموع
باتجاه المتظاهرين اشعل الشبان المشاركون
اطارات المطاطيه قرب السياج الامنيه
تمديدا بالاعتداءات على المسجد الاقصى
ومطالبه بكسر الحصار الاسرائيلي على قطاع
غزه
قال سفير كوريا الشماليه في الامم المتحده
سون كيم ان شبه الجزيره الكوريه كانت على
شفا حرب نوويه بسبب تصرفات الولايات
المتحده وحلفائها وفق تعبيره وتعمل مندوب
في كلمه امام الجمعيه العامه للامم
المتحده واشنطن بالتحريض على حرب نوويه
بارسالها اسلحه الاستراتيجيه النوويه لاول
مره منذ عقود الى المنطقه حسب قوله
نظرا للهستيريا المتهوره والمستمره
المتصله بالمواجهه النوويه من جانب واشنطن
والقوات التابعه لها سجل عام 2023 على انه
عام بالغ الخطوره فيما يتعلق بالوضع
الامني العسكري في شبه الجزيره الكوريه
وما حولها حيث اقتربت من شفا حرب نوويه
منذ بدايه العام اطلقت واشنطن وكوريا
الجنوبيه تصريحات هستيريه وخطاب مواجهه في
انتهاك صارخ لمبادئ الامم المتحده كما تم
اجراء مناورات عسكريه مشتركه ذات طبيعه
عدوانيه على عتبه بابنا
هذا وحذر الامين العام للعوام المتحده من
مخاطر التلويح باستخدام السلاح النووي
وقال في اجتماع
واجتماعا بمناسبه اليوم العالمي لازاله
السلاح النووي ان هناك سباقه تسلح جديدا
مثيرا للقلق وان الهيكله الدوريه لمنع
انتشار الاسلحه النوويه اخذ في التاكل على
حد تعبيره
عدد الاسلحه النوويه يرتفع للمره الاولى
منذ عقود والمعايير التي تم التوصل اليها
بشق الانفس لمنع استخدامها وانتشارها
واختبارها يتم تقويضها الهيكل العالمي
لنزع السلاح وعدم الانتشار اخذ في التاكل
يجري تحديث الترسانه النوويه لجعل هذه
الاسلحه اسرع واكثر دقه وقدره على التخفي
ويجري التلويح بهذا السلاح مره اخرى هذا
جنون ادعو الدول الحائزه للاسلحه النوويه
الى الوفاء بالتزاماتها في مجال نزع
السلاح وعدم استخدامه مطلقا تحت اي ظرف
مشاهدونا مستمرون معكم في الحصاد وفي
عناوينه
تحدد مساراتهما بعد اعلان باريس سحب
قواتها المتحدث باسم المجلس العسكري يقول
للجزيره انه لا توجد مشكله مع قوات الدول
الاخرى والمجلس لم يطلب قوات بديله عن
القوات الفرنسيه وباريس تقول ان بازون هو
رئيس النيجر الوحيد والمنتخب ديمقراطيه
مع فرار قرابه الثلاثين الف من ارمل
كهرباء خيار مينيا خلال ايام بلنكن يشدد
في اتصال مع الرئيس الاذربيجاني على وجوب
حمايه مدني الاقليم اذربيجان تؤكد ان
الفرصه سانحه للمضي قدما في التطبيع مع
ارمينيا والاتحاد الاوروبي يرعى محادثات
بين الطرفين في بروكسل
هجوم جوي روسي على البنيه التحتيه لموانئ
وصوامع للحبوب باوكرانيا
بعد تسليمها لاوكرانيا وانقطاع التيار
الكهربائي عن بلدات روسيه بعد ضربه
اوكرانيه وازلنسكي يقول ان بلاده تبحث عن
شركاء جدد لامدادات الذخيه
[موسيقى]
السلام عليكم واهلا بكم في الساعه الثانيه
من الحصاد قال الناطق الرسمي وباسم المجلس
العسكري في النيجر ووزيره الشباب والرياضه
والثقافه العقيده عبد الرحمن امادو ان
المجلس لم يتسلم حتى الان اي بيان رسمي
بشان انسحاب القوات الفرنسيه من بلاده وفي
مقابلته مع الجزيره اضافها المتحدث
العسكري ان المجلس لم يطلب قوه بديله
للجنود الفرنسيه
لقد سمعنا بهذا الموضوع من خلال وسائل
الاعلام الفرنسيه حين اعلن الرئيس ماكرون
سحب سفيره وقوات بلاده ونحن كحكومه ومجلس
وطني ننتظر ان يستتبع هذا الاعلان ببيان
رسمي وكذلك الفتنا النظر الى انه بالنسبه
الى انسحاب القوات الفرنسيه يجب ان يحصل
ذلك ضمن اطار يتم التفاوض عليه من اجل
ضمان نجاحه وفعاليته وحتى الان لم يردنا
اي بيان او اعلان رسمي بشانه هذا الموضوع
كما اكد النطق الرسمي وباسم المجلس
العسكري في النيجر العقيد عبد الرحمن
عمادو في مقابلته مع الجزيره انه لا توجد
اي مشكله مع قوات الدول الاخرى في النيجر
ولن يطلب منها الانسحاب
فيما يتعلق بقوات الدول الاخرى في النيجر
فعلى حد علمي لا توجد اي مشكله معها ليست
لدينا اي مشكله مع القوات الاخرى وكالعاده
نحن نعمل مع من يرغب في العمل معنا بطريقه
تعاونيه هذا ما قلناه دائما واحب ان اشير
هنا بان فرنسا هي التي قررت وقف التعاون
معنا ما دفعنا الى انهاء ذلك التعاون الذي
كان يجمعنا بها لكن القوات الاخرى لم تعلق
التعاون معنا وبالتالي لا داعي لان نطلب
انسحابها
هذا واوضحت المتحدثه باسم الخارجات
الفرنسيه
ان اعلان الرئيس الفرنسي مارويل ماكرون
سحب سفير بلاده من نيامي ومغادره القوات
الفرنسيه بحلول نهايه هذا العام تم بعد
اتصال هاتفي اجراه مع الرئيس محمد بازو
وذكرت المتحدثه باسم الخارجيه الفرنسيه ان
الرئيس بزوم هو في نظر باريس رئيس النيجر
الوحيد والمنتخب ديمقراطيه واضافت ان
فرنسا تواصل جهودها دعما لدول الاقواس من
اجل استعاده النظام الدستوري في النيجر
وفيما يتعلق بوضع السفير الفرنسي قالت
المتحدثه باسم الخارجيه الفرنسيه انها لا
تملك اي تعليق تقدمه بشان الاجراءات
المتعلقه بعودته الى باريس
معنى من ولايه نورث كارولينا الدكتور
كاميرون هاتسن المسؤول في شؤون افريقيا
السابق في البيت الابيض قوات الولايات
المتحده باقيه في النيجر قوات المانيا
باقيه في النيجر وقواعدها كذلك
لماذا يبدو الموقف الى مختلفا والموقف
الالماني ايضا مختلفا كثيرا عن الموقف
الفرنسي
لانني لا اعتقد ان المانيا او الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه لديهما نفس الارث في
المقارنه مع فرنسا هناك غضب وجه باتجاه
فرنسا ولكنه لم يوجه باتجاه بلدان اخرى
لديها تواجد في مجال مكافحه الارهاب في
ذلك البلد هذا هو السبب الاول والسبب
الثاني بالنسبه الى الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه هو ان النيجر هي منصه اساسيه
لجمع المعلومات الاستخباريه لكل المنطقه
واشنطن استثمرت بشكل كبير بقواعد قويه في
النيجر وليست مستعده لتركي هذه القواعد
وان تتوقف عن عمليه جمع المعلومات
الاستخباريه لمكافحه الارهاب في
مالي وفي الجنوب الافريقي وبالتالي النيجر
هو نقطه اساسيه بالنسبه الى واشنطن
اعتقد ان الولايات المتحده الامريكيه الان
لا تنخرطوا في عمل مكافحه الارهاب مع
العسكريين في النيجر هي تتصرف بشكل منفصل
من خلال القواعد وقد علقت التعاون العسكري
حتى حل هذه المساله بالنسبه الى عمليه اخذ
الرهينه بشكل اساسي التي لا تزال مستمره
في البلاد وبالتالي واشنطن لم تقبل المجلس
العسكري بعد وهي تستمر بالانخراط بعمل
الدبلوماسي والتقت بقاده اقليميين على
هامشي الجميع العامه للامم المتحده الوزير
بلينكن تطلع في هذه الاجتماعات الى حلول
للازمه مع شركاء اعتقد انه في الوقت
الراهن واشنطن تستمر في صون مصالحها
الامنيه من خلال تحليق الطائرات المسيره
فوق النيجر وفي اجواء المنطقه وسوف تستمر
في هذا العمل الى اطول فتره ممكنه الا في
حال تغير اي شيء ولكنها وضعت خطا في
الرمال الاساسي لا يمكن ان يتم تخطيه وهو
تقديم المساعده العسكريه المباشره الى
النيجر وهو ما لا تقومه تقوم به الان
فيما يتعلق باعاده الرئيس بازون ما هو
موقف الولايات المتحده
مجددا اعتقد ان واشنطن تنظر باتجاه حلا
خلاق هي تفهم انها وبشكل اساسي لا يمكنها
ان تغادر بلدا من مثل النيجر اولا نحن
نتحدث عن وضع امنيا في البلاد سوف يستمر
ان يتراجع وسوف يفسح ذلك في المجال امام
الجهاديين لكي يحصلوا على القدره على
الوصول في البلاد وهي محاولات متكرره
قاموا بها وايضا يفصح في المجال امام
روسيا وامام القوات الروسيه غير العسكريه
او الغير الرسميه ان تصل الى البلاد
واشنطن تود ان تدعم الديمقراطيه وتحافظ
على مصالحها الامنيه وفي الوقت نفسه يجب
ان نتذكر ان هناك
تدبير واتجاهات جيو استراتيجيه واجيو
سياسيه مهمه في المنطقه واشتن تفهم ذلك
ولا تود ان تتخذ قرارات تغلق
ابوابا عليها وتفتح ابوابا امام منافسيها
في المنطقه وبالتالي هذا حبل رفيع وخيط
رفيع تسير عليه واشنطن شكرا جزيلا لك من
ولايه نورس
السابق في البيت الابيض
[موسيقى]
سياسيا بدا حراك غربي لتطبيع العلاقات بين
ارمينيا واذربيجان وهذا كان محور محدثه
بين الجانبين في بروكسل برعايه اوروبيه
كما اعلنت مديره الوكاله الامريكيه
للتنميه
ان واشنطن ستقدم مساعدات انسانيه لسكان
الكهرباء وفي المقابل اجر رئيس الايراني
ابراهيم رئيسي وحدثات مع نظيره الروسيه
لدمر بوتين بشان الوضع في كنبا
فرصه تاريخيه لتطبيع العلاقات بين
اذربيجان وارمينيا هذا ما يقوله المسؤولون
في باكو اذ يطفئون نيران صراع كرباخ لكن
ما ترغب به باكو وما قد تضطر اليه ريفان
خاضع لا محاله لحسابات ومصالح حلفاء
الطرفين وعليه يدخل خلاف البلدين حلبه
صراع النفوذ بين روسيا والغرب تشترك ايران
في حدود مع اذربيجان وارمينيا تجد طهران
نفسها اكثر المعنيين بكل ما يحدث في
جارتيها السوفيتيتين السابقتين يجري
الرئيس الايراني ابراهيم رئيس محادثات مع
نظيره الروسي فلاديمير بوتين فروسيا هي
الوسيط التاريخي بين ارمينيا واذربيجان
خلال 30 عاما من الحرب في اقليم كرباخ في
المقابل يتوافد المسؤولون الغربيون على
الحدود بين البلدين تصل ثمان سباور معلنه
عن دعم مالي امريكي لسكان كاراباخ من
الاقليم الذي اصبح فعليا جزءا من اراضي
اذربيجان وفي بروكسل يلتقي المسؤولون
الاذربيجانيون والارمينيون لبحث تطبيع
العلاقات بين باكو وريفان تجري اللقاءات
بواسطه الاتحاد الاوروبي وبدعم واشنطن
وبمباركه تركيا حاليا في اذربيجان الاقرب
والحقيقه ان مصالح كبيره قد تدفع لتطبيع
العلاقات بين الجارتين اللدودتين تسعى
اذربيجان الى الحصول على موافقه ارمينيا
لاقامه خط زينجازور للسكك الحديديه لاعاده
اتصال اذربيجان باقليم ثم الى الاراضي
التركيه والفضاء الاوروبي من ورائها
بدورها تصر الحكومه الارمينيه على ضمان
اذربيجان لحقوق ارمن كرباخ خاصه الحقوق
الثقافيه واللغه الارمينيه وسهوله تنقلهم
عبر الحدود الغاز لربما هو كلمه سر في حسم
صراع كرباخ فليذر بيجان مصلحه لانهاء
الصراع الطويل الامد للتفرغ لمشاريع ربط
الطاقه بين البلدين فما ان حسم صراع
الكهرباء حتى وضع الرئيسان التركي
والاذربيجانيه حجر الاساس لخط
وقد ابدت الدول الغربيه حرصا على علاقات
جيده مع اذربيجان التي اصبحت الان مركزا
مهما لتصدير الطاقه الى اوروبا في ظل
مساعي بروكسل الى تنويع مصادر الطاقه
بعيدا عن روسيا ينقل الغاز من اذربيجان
الى اوروبا من خلال خط تناب العابر
الاناضول والذي يربط حقول الغاز
الاذربيجانيه في بحر قزوين بجورجيا وتركيا
ومن ثم الى الاتحاد الاوروبي وكذلك خط غاز
تاب الذي ينقل الغاز الاذربيجاني الى
اوروبا عبر البحر الادرياتيكي اما ارمينيا
فهي معنيه بفتح بوابه لها نحو الاتحاد
الاوروبي عبر تركيا من خلال اعاده فتح
المعابر الحدوديه بين البلدين خطوه ستحدث
ان طبعت العلاقات بين باكو وريفان تتطلع
ارمينيا ايضا لان تحلق طائراتها عبر
الاجواء التركيه وتطمح باذن من انقره يتيح
لشركه الطيران الارمنيه تشغيل رحلات الى
اوروبا عبر المجال الجوي التركي
[موسيقى]
ولمعرفه كيف اثرت هذه المصالح وهذه الخطوط
من النفط والغاز على المقاربات من الاطراف
المختلفه ينضموا لنا من بروكسل بيتر
الكاتب المختص في الشؤون الاوروبيه ورئيس
تحرير موقع
الباحث في المجلس
الروسي للشؤون الدوليه ونبدا
بروكسيل من السيد كليبي
ولعلك السماعة معنا الى هذا التقرير فيه
كثير من الغاز كثير من الخطوط كثير من
المصالح التي تتقاطع
كثير من المساعي لتطبيع العلاقات مع بين
اذربيجان وارمينيا لان هذا يخدم الجميع
كيف اثر ذلك على المقاربه الغربيه من صراع
ناغورنو كارابا
في الحقيقه ان الربطه او الرابط بالنسبه
الى الغرب اساسي بكلمه واحده الغاز مع
تراجع الغاز من روسيا الاتحاد الاوروبي
اصبح معتمدا بشكل اكبر على المصادر
البديله وازار البادجان هي من بين هذه
المصادر البديله واعتقد ان ذلك من بين
الاسباب التي تدفع اوروبا كي لا تتخذ
خطوات متقدمه للغايه بالنسبه الى ما يحصل
الان وهذا يعني ان
ارمن
كاراباخ يعانون او يخشون من تطهير عرقي
كانوا يعيشون في الاقليم منذ سنوات طويله
الوضع معقد للغايه نحن نعرف ان هناك رسما
للحدود كان غريبا في الماضي سياسه فرق
تسود هي التي سادت بعد انه الاتحاد
السوفيتي كان هناك ايضا حربا في العام
[موسيقى]
والان هناك عمليه عسكريه جاريه هذا معقد
للغايه وهناك نزوح في الاجانبين ولكنني
اعتقد انه في سياق مختلف لو كانت اوروبا
لو لم تكن معتمده بشكل كبير على الغاز من
اذربيجان لكن الموقف يتغير وهنالك تغير
ايضا في المقاربه الروسيه السيد
ما الذي غير المقاربه الروسيه يعني في
روسيا دعمت ارمينيا طوال الوقت في هذا
الصراع منذ بدايته وكانت مسؤوله كما ذكر
ضيفنا عن اسباب هذا الصراع
بسياسه فرق تسود بالتغيير الديموغرافي
الذي حصل في المنطقه بمساعده ارمينيا
عسكريا ما الذي غير المقاربه الروسيه
[موسيقى]
مقاربه روسيا تجاهها ارمينيا وازرباجان
معقده لطالما كانت معقده في خلال حرب
ناجون وكرباخ في التسعينيات وهي الحرب
الاولى القوات الروسيه قاتلت لصالح
ارمينيا في مواجهه اذربيجان ولصالح
اذربيجان في مواجهه ارمينيا ولكن منذ تسلم
زمام السلطه بعد الثوره العلاقه بين روسيا
وارمينيا كانت تتراجع المشكله بالنسبه الى
ارمينيا هي انها ورسميا حليفه لروسيا وفقا
لمعاهده تحالف ولكن روسيا لا تحصل على اي
شيء ازاءه هذا التعاون ارمينيا ليست شريكا
اقتصاديا او سياسيا موثوقا به ارمينيا
تحاول ان تنسج العلاقات مع الغرب وذلك على
مصلحه الاتحاد الروسي من ناحيه اخرى
اثبتت انها من بين الحلفاء التي يمكن ان
يعتمد عليهم وايضا ذلك مهم بالنسبه الى
تركيا وهي نقطه اساسيه منذ بدايه العمليه
العسكريه الروسيه في اوكرانيا ولذلك
يبدو انها حليف اكثر موثوقيه ومنذ العام
2022 وكما تعرفون اذربيجان هي حليف لروسيا
كان هناك توقيع في فبراير لاعلان بين
الطرفين يعني تحول غريب في هذا الملف ملف
كارباخو ملف
اذربيجان وارمينيا لكن ايضا هنالك دعم
غربي واضح لارمينيا سيد اليك
من بروكسل يعني حينما اندلعت الحرب
الاخيره ليست هذه ولكن ما قبلها التي
اسفرت على كل هذه الاتفاقات
ذهبت نايل سبيلوسي رئيسه مجلس نوبل
الامريكيه الى
الان هنالك ثمان تباور وهنالك مساعده وزير
الخارجيه الامريكي مع حدود الدعم الغربي
لسيما ان اللغه المستخدمه هو دعم سياره
ارمينيا ولا شيء عن كراباخس ودعم الانساني
انا اعتقد ان ديمقراطيات الغربيه لديها
مخاوف مرتبطه
بسياده ارمينيا والتاكد من عدم نزوح
الارمن ولربما هي نقطه اهم من مساله
السياده وخصوصا في ذاك الجزء من العالم
ولكن نعم المصالح بالنسبه الى هذا الملف
مصالح غريبه ومتشابكه اذربيجان هي حليف
اسرائيل الولايات المتحده الامريكيه هي
حليف كبير لاسرائيل طبعا وبالنسبه الى
العلاقات بين اذربيجان وايران طبعا ايران
هي حليفه روسيا ولكن كما ذكر الضيف هناك
علاقه الان بين روسيا واذربيجان في الوقت
نفسه اذا الجميع يحاول ان يبقي على علاقات
الود
الجميع الى حد ما وطبعا هناك بعض القصص
التي نسمعها وهي ان الحكومه الارمنيه لا
تعتمد بنفس القدر على روسيا لانه لربما
روسيا غير قادره على دعمها لربما تودوا
الحكومه الارمنيه ان تتوجه الى الغرب ربما
لديها سياسه تمزج بين الامرين ولكن الغرب
والولايات المتحده الامريكيه ليس
باستطاعتها ان تمنع ما يحصل هناك وضع
سؤالا حول نظره روسيا لارميليا الان يعني
روسيا في غمره حرب مع اوكرانيا صيدليكسيه
مثل الخشيه الروسيه من
التقارب ارمينيا مع الغرب
يمكنني ان اقول لكم انني لا ارى الكثير من
الخوف او المخاوف في عيوني الخبراء الروس
الارمينيون يتحدثون كثيرا الجميع يعرف
انهم تاذوا بعد هذه الحرب كان بسطاتهم ان
يقدموا التنازلات
ويتفادى النتيجه ولكن في خلال السنوات
الثلاثين منذ عام 1994 منذ ابره بوقف
اطلاق النار لم تقم ارمينيا باي شيء
ارمينيا لا يمكنها ان تذهب الى الغرب
جغرافيا وسياسيا واقتصاديا نعم هي جريحه
وتتحدث كثيرا ولكن بالنظر الى الموقع
الجغرافي هذه النقله غير ممكنه ارمينيا لا
يمكنها ان تصبح اوكرانيا اخرى واعتذر على
هذه المقارنه لانها ليس لديها اي حدود مع
دول غربيه ولا احسب تركي على انها دوله
الغربيه تركيا هي حليف قوي لازار باجان
وبالتالي ارمينيا ملزمه بعلاقات عمل مع
روسيا لا اعتقد ان الجانب الارميني يمكنه
ان يتخطى الازمه بالعوده الى الغرب او
الاتجاه الى الغرب من موسكو
الباحث في المجلس الروسي للشؤون الدوليه
كما نشكر ضيفنا من بروكسل
الكاتب المختص في الشؤون الاوروبيه ورئيس
تحرير موقع
ارتفع عدد ضحايا مستودع للوقود في مدينه
ستيفانا كارت باقليم كهربا خلال 67 وقالت
وزاره الصحه في المنطقه الواقعه في جنوب
القوقاز
168 شخصا اصيب جراء الانفجار اصابات بعضهم
خطيره للغايه وقد نقلوا الى المستشفى في
العاصمه الارمنيه يريفان وبينهم 96 ننقل
بواسطه مروحيه ارمينيه وروسيه ولم يتضح
بعده سبب الانفجار
[موسيقى]
الان الى ملف حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا وقد
توعدت موسكو على لسان المتحدث باسم الكربل
الديمتري بحرق دبابات ابرمز الامريكيه
التي سلمتها كييف من الولايات المتحده
وحضر ايضا نائب رئيس مجلس الامن القوميه
الروسي
من اندلاع صراع المباشر مع الغرب وجاء
التهديد في يوم حافل بلا جماه والهجمات
المضاده في اوكرانيا اذا الحق القصف
الروسي بالمسيره اضرارا كبيره بميناء
اسماعيل الذي تستخدمه اوكرانيا في الشهور
الاخيره لتصدير الحبوب
الحب التي لا تعرف استراحه لا ليلى ولا
نهارا لا في السماء ولا على اليابسه
والبحر دمى الرعب خلال القصف الروسي
بصواريخ ومسيرات على ميناء اسماعيل المطل
على نهر الدانوب باوديسا ساعتين من هنا
كانت تصدر الحبوب الى الخارج بعد انسحاب
موسكو من اتفاق تعذر تمديده اذ وصلت
المفاوضات الى طريق مسدود اعتراض القوات
الاوكرانيه لمعظم المسيرات المشاركه في
الهجوم وفق روايتها لم يمنع تفاديا الحاق
اضرار كبيره بالميناء والمستودعات وحجز
التفتيش لم يتاخر ردوا كييف التي قصفت
محطه كهرباء فرعيه في منطقه كورسك الروسيه
تحدث حاكم المنطقه الحدوديه عن انقطاع
الكهرباء عن سبع بلدات جراء الهجوم من
جهته اعلن الحاكم الروسي لمدينه سيفا
ستوبول احباط هجوم صاروخي قرب مطار بيليبك
حرب المسيرات المتبادله بين المتقاتلين في
الصراع تقابلها شبهه مشتعله يزعم كل طرف
انه يحقق تقدما فيها تراهن وتتفاءل كياف
بترشيح الكفه لصالحها بعد وصوله اول دفعه
من دبابات ابرامز الامريكيه التي طال
انتظارها والموعود رسميا منذ يناير الماضي
لم يفوت الرئيس فلودي مرزليسك الفرصه
ليلقي كلمه ترحيبا بالدبابات التي بحث
صوته وهو يطالب بها مع منظومه صواريخ
اتاكمز لا تفرح كثيرا رد عليه اكثر من
مسؤول روسي بعد هذا الخطاب توعد المتحدث
باسم الكريم
بحرق تلك الدبابات واوضح قائلا انه لا
يوجد علاج سحري ولا سلاح يمكنه تغيير
ميزان القوه في ساحه المعركه
تعاهدت واشنطن بتزويد كييف باحدى وثلاثين
مزوده بذخائره تحتوي على اليورانيوم
المنظم بعيار 120 ملم ذخيره مثيره للجدل
بسبب مخاطرها السامه على الجيش والمدنيين
بنبره حاده انتقد مجددا نائب رئيس مجلس
الامن الروسي
تدفق السلاح الغربي الثقيل على اوكرانيا
هدد بان الخيارات امام روسيا
تتضاءلوا ومنها خيار المواجهه المباشره مع
النيتو الذي تحول الى كتله فاشيه شبيهه
بمحور هتلر على حد تعبيره نتائج محاور
المعارك المباشره او غير المباشره في هذا
الصراع اما غير ثابته او غير واضحه في حرب
الكل يخرج فيها ما بقي من اوراق وسلاح
وعتاد بحثا عن حسم مفقود ولا يبدو قريبا
تكلفه الحرب الانسانيه قبل الماديه على
الجميع باهظه ومؤلمه
وبخسائر قد تستمر عقودا طوال
هذا ليس الاوكراني
الخدمات اللوجستيه ومقرات القوات الروسيه
في شرق وجنوب البلاد واكد هذا لنسكي في
كلمه المتلفزه ان حكومته تبحث عن شركاء
جدد الامدادات الذخيره وصفا العقوبات على
روسيا بغير الكافيه
العقوبات ليست كافيه سيكون هناك المزيد من
اجراءاتنا ضد الدوله الارهابيه طالما
العدوان الروسي مستمر فيجب ان تشعر روسيا
بالخسائر
في الوقت نفسه قال الكلام لان دبابات
الامريكيه لن تغير الوضع في ساحه القتال
وكان مسؤولون امريكيون قالوا الاسبوع
الماضي ان الرئيس جو بايدن ابلغ نظيره
الاوكراني بلودي ان واشنطن ستقدم عددا
محدودا من هذه الصواريخ وهي صواريخ ارض
ارض بعيده المدى وذلك للمساعدتها في الحرب
مع روسيا في التقرير التالي يلقي الزميل
زاهر علي الضوء على اهميته هذه الصواريخ
وقدرتها العسكريه
منظومه التكامس تعرف بانها صواريخ
باليستيه بعيده المدى موجهه وشديده الدقه
يصل مداها الى نحو ثلاثمئه كيلومتر ويمكن
اطلاقها من منصات متحركه كراجمات الصواريخ
هايمارس هذا الصاروخ مصمم لمهاجمه الاهداف
الاستراتيجيه كالمطارات ومواقع صواريخ
ارجوا وقوات المدفعيه ومناطق الامداد
ومجموعات القياده او نقاط الاتصالات اما
عن حركته الجويه فان ارتفاع صاروخ التكامز
يتراوح من 50 الى 65 كيلو مترا ويسمح هذا
الارتفاع للصاروخ بتجنب معظم انظمه الدفاع
ارض جو مع الحفاظ على الدقه اللازمه
للضربات
اما عن سرعته فتصلوا الى حوالي ثلاثه الاف
وسبعمائه كيلو متر في الساعه ويبلغ طوله
اربعه امتار ووزن راسه الحربي بين 160
و560 كيلو جراما اضافه الى ان تصميم
الصاروخ الذي يعمل بالوقود الصلب يجعله
مناسبا للعمل في بيئات متنوعه
وتعتمد صواريخ اتكامز على راس حربي ينشا
عنه انفجار تعادل شدته القوه التفجيريه
لنحو 28
كيلو جراما من ماده تي ان تي وتواجه عن
طريق الملاحه وبمساعده نظام تحديد المواقع
جي بي اس
هذا الصاروخ موجود لدى القوات البريه
الاميركيه منذ عام
1990 واطلق منه
450 صاروخا خلال غزو العراق عام
2003 وفيما بعد عام 2015 اطلق اكثر من 500
وستين صاروخا من نظام التكانز في حروب عده
[موسيقى]
ولاحقا في فقره المتابعه نسلط الضوء على
تحذير
نائب رئيس مجلس الامن القومي الروسي من
انه لم يعد امام موسكو سوى الصراع المباشر
مع النيتو ونستر ضيف الحصاد عن قدرات
الجانبين
[موسيقى]
قالت مصادر ومحاليل للجزيره ان الجيش
السوداني شن سلسله غاره بطائرات المسيره
استهدفت مواقع قوات الدعم السريع في عدد
من الاحياء الشرقيه النيل وفي غضون ذلك
ذكرت مصادر محليه ان قوات الدعم السريع
اطلقت الرصاصه بكثافه لساعات من اسلحه
المضادات الارضيه التابعه لها ويتزامن ذلك
مع اشتداد الازمه الاقتصاديه في السودان
في ظل زياده عدد النازحين
لم يهدا بعد المعارك مستمره دون مؤشر على
قرب نهايتها على الارض استهدف الجيش
السوداني مواقع لقوات الدعم السريع
وبغارات بالطائرات المسيره في عدد من
الاحياء شرق النيل من بينها الجريف شرقي
العاصمه والمدينه الرياضيه وحي المجاهدين
جنوبي الخرطوم كما قصف الجيش بالمدفعيه
اهدافا لقوات الدعم السريع وسط غرب مدينه
ام درمان والخرطوم بحري تزامنا مع هذه
الغارات تحدثت مصادر محليه عن اطلاق قوات
الدعم السريع للرصاصي كثافه ولساعات من
اسلحه المضادات الارضيه التابعه لها ليس
بعيدا عن ساحه المعركه يتم تمديد حاله
الطوارئ لمده شهر بولايه الجزيره المتاخمه
للعاصمه الخرطوم من الجنوب وهي الولايه
التي تستضيف مئات الالاف من الفارينه من
الحرب رغم تمركز قوات الدعم السريع في
شمالها حيث يصنف هذا الجزء من الولايه
منطقه عمليات حربيه بين ضباب الدخان
المتصاعد من لهب المعارك يختنق الاف
السودانيين بالتداعيات الاقتصاديه لهذه
الحرب ملايين النازحين في السودان وعددهم
الاعلى الان في العالم يكافحون من اجل
البقاء البعض منهم يعود الى العاصمه باحثا
عن لقمه عيش رغم الاقتتال في ظل الارتفاع
اسعارها في مناطق اخرى سواء العائدون الى
العاصمه او الذين لم يعودوا اليها الكل
يواجه سوق عمل مشلوله تزيد الوضع هشاشه
الوضع الذي يئن تحت ظروف سوء التغذيه
والتغير المناخي والصعوبه وصول المساعدات
ارقام الامم المتحده تؤكد نزوح اكثر من
خمسه ملايين نسمه من سكان السودان منذ
اندلاع القتال انتقل اكثر من مليون منهم
الى البلدان المجاوره ومن تبقوا في
السودان فيرزحون تحت ركود اقتصادي خانق
تغذيه الحرب كل ثانيه
وانضم الينا هنا في الاستوديو ضياء الدين
بلال الكاتب والمحلل السياسي
السوداني يعني اشهر عديده مرت على بدء هذه
الحرب ولا تبدو هنالك نهايه في الافق ما
الذي يمنع نهايته
نعم هذه الحرب حرب استثنائيه ومعقده جدا
لانتشار واسع لغات الدعم السريع باعداد
كبيره في الخرطوم العاصمه
هذه الحرب تسير على مسارين مسار متعلق
بالصراع المحتدل ما بين الجيش والدعم
السريع والصراع اخر تخوضه قوات الدعم
السريع ضد المجتمع السوداني ككل ضد المكون
المدني الموجود في العاصمه وموجود في بعض
الولايات من خلال احتلال المنازل ومن خلال
احتال احتلال المستشفيات
وممارسه السلب والنهب وكل هذه
السلوكيات فبالتالي تجعل من هذه الحرب
حاله استثنائيه يصعب التنبؤ
بتوقيت زمني لنهايتها هي تمضي باشكال
مختلفه والجيش يحاول ان ان يقلل خسائر
المدنيه المترتبه التي يمكن ان تترتب على
مقاومه
المشروع الانقلاب للدعم السريع ويتجه
الى خيارات قريبه لذلك هي الاستخدام
المسيرات باستخدام القوات
الخاصه وغير ذلك لكن لا نستطيع ان نقول
بان هذه الحرب يمكن ان نحدد لها ميقات
زمنيا بشكل مفصل يعني السودان شاهد حروبا
من قبل
هنالك حروب استمرت عقودا كحرب الجنوب حروب
استمرت سنوات عديده كدارفور هل نحن
مشابهين نعم
ربما تكون هنالك عوامل مختلفه بعض الشيء
كانت هنالك عوامل كثيره في تلك الحروب اذا
كان في الجنوب السودان او في دارفورد هنا
هنالك تعقيدات تواجه الجيش في هذه
العمليات العسكريه ولكن لا اعتقد انها
تعقيدات تمنع انتصاره على الدعم السريع
خاصه ان هنالك معطى اخر وهو محطه اقليمي
ودولي دولي ينظر الان الى الماساه
الانسانيه المترتبه لهذه على هذه الحرب
وعلى المخاطر كذلك التي يمكن ان تترتب على
هذه الحرب على الجوار السوداني يجاور مصر
وعلى جوار مائي مع المملكه العربيه
السعوديه وله جوار مع مناطق
ذات هشاشه امنيه اصلا
امنيه فبالتالي من المتوقع لا يكون هنالك
صبر ممتد بالنسبه للاقليم او بالنسبه
للمجتمع الدولي
يمكن ان تمارس ضغوطات مختلفه اذا لم يكن
الضغط الاساسي الذي يمارس سيمارس على
الطرفين يمكن ان يمارس على الجهات التي
تمول هذه الحرب واضحه ان هذه الحرب
بالاسلحه التي تستخدم خاصه من قبل الدعم
السريع بان هنالك اطراف
لها مقدرات ولها
نفوز ولها تاثير كبير على مجريات الحرب من
خلال الدعم العسكري والدعم الذي يقدم
للدعم السريع فاذا كانت هنالك الضغوطات
باشكال مختلفه خاصه من المجتمع الدولي على
هذه الاطراف اعتقد ان ذلك
سيعجل بانهاء الحرب شكرا جزيلا لك سجاد
بلال الكاتب والمحلل السياسي السوداني
[موسيقى]
الولايات المتحده
ركزته منذ اليوم الاول لهذه الاداره على
تحقيق اتفاق سلام شامل في اليمن وجمع
اطراف النزاع تحت مظله الامم المتحده
وهناك تقدم جيد احرز في هذا الملف في
السنه والنصف الماضيه التي شهدت خفضا
للتصعيد باستثناء الحادث المؤسف الذي حصل
الاثنين الماضي واضافه الى خفض التصعيد
جرى فتح مطار صنعاء امام الطائرات
التجاريه وتم نزع العراقيل المرتبطه
بايصال النفط والمعدات الى اليمن وجرا
تبادل الاسرى اضافه الى زياره وفد الحوث
الى الرياض وكانت هناك مباحثات ايجابيه
اعتقد ان كل هذه النقاط مهمه وتمنحنا
الامل ولذلك يتعين علينا ان نمضي قدما في
هذه الجهود
اكد رئيس هيئه الطاقه الذريه الايرانيه
محمد اسلامي من بلاده تتعاون مع او تتعاون
بشكل جيد مع الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه
الذريه واوضح في تصريح للجزيره ان نحو 120
مفتشا من الوكاله معتمدون حاليا لدى طيران
في هذا الوقت اكثر من 120 مفتشا مقبولون
ومعتمدون لدى ايران وهم يعملون فعليا واذا
كنا نرفض عدد القليل منهم فهذا حقنا فنحن
نراقب تصرفاتهم ومن حقنا قبول او رفض اي
منهم وقرار عدم قبول بعضهم لا يعني ان
ايران لا تتعاون بل نحن نتعاون مع الوكاله
وهذا التعاون نسقه يومي متواصل ولكن بسبب
تصرف بعض المفتشين رفضوا وهذا عدي ومعمول
به
واكد رئيس هيئه الطاقه الذريه الايرانيه
محمد اسلامي ضروره توقف الضغوط السياسيه
التي تمارس على ايران واعتبر في تصريح
للجزيره ان عده قضايا تلام عليها طهران
وهي نجمه عن معلومات مزيفه مختلقه من قبل
اعدائها وفق تعبيرها
نتمنى ان تتوقف الضغوط والتاثيرات
السياسيه التي مرشت علينا خلال السنوات
العشرين الماضيه بل يجب ان تتوقف لان ما
يلوموننا عليه مزيف وهي معلومات مختلقه من
قبل اعدائنا كل انشطتنا مبنيه على نظام
الضمانات وسنواصل عملنا فبرنامجنا معلوم
على الصعيد الدولي فهم يعلمون اهدافنا
ويعلمون بوضوح تفاصيل ما تفعله ايران في
كل منشاتها من خلال ما نقدمه من تفاصيله
وتوضيحات للوكاله
قالت وكاله رجل الاعمال وائل حنا المتهم
في قضيه السنه الامريكي بوب قد القي القبض
عليه صباح الثلاثاء في مطار جون كندي
بنيويورك وقد دفع حنا الذي يحمل الجنسيتين
الامريكيه والمصريه ببراءته من تهم رشوه
السيناتور الامريكي
وكانت هيئه محلفين كبرى بولايه نيويورك قد
وجهت تهما لباب مينينندس وزوجته
بتلقي ريشن من ثلاثه رجال اعمال على علاقه
بالحكومه المصريه ومن بين التهم التي وجه
بها سعيه عام 2018
لاقناع البيت الابيض بالافراج عن 300
مليون دولار من المساعرات المخصصه لمصر
[موسيقى]
في العاصمه الهنديه التقى قاده الجيوش
وضباط من كبار من ثلاثين دوله بينهم
الولايات المتحده لبحث التعديلات التي
تواجه منطقه اسيا والمحيط الهادئ وذلك مع
تصاعد نفوذ الصين التي تعمل على ترسيخ
وجودها في المنطقه
محفل عسكري واسع النطاق في العاصمه
الهنديه قاده جيوش ثلاثين دوله يلتقون في
نيودلهي في مقدمتهم رئيس الاركان الامريكي
الجديد راندي جورج ونظيره الهندي مع
نوجباندي يبحث الاجتماع التهديدات التي
تواجه منطقه اسيا والمحيط الهادئ على وقع
تصاعد سعي الصين لتعزيز نفوذها هناك
هذه المنطقه ذات اهميه بالغه بالنسبه لنا
واعتقد انكم رايتم ذلك من خلال استراتيجيه
الدفاعيه الوطنيه هذه اولويه وجيشنا منتشر
في جميع انحاء العالم لكننا لتلك الاهميه
نجري تدريبات هنا اكثر من اي مكان اخر في
المحيط الهادئ تعهد جورج ايضا بالحفاظ على
منطقه المحيطين الهندي والهادئ حره
ومفتوحه قائد جيش الهند الدوله المضيفه
اكد من جانبه ان الاجتماع التدريبات
العسكريه المرتقبه ليست موجهه ضد احد الا
ان استضافه الهند للاجتماع وانخراطها في
تعاون عسكري وثيق مع الولايات المتحده لا
يلغي خصوصيه موقفها كحليف تقليدي لموسكو
ولعلها بالتقارب مع واشنطن ربما تسعى لمسك
العصا من المنتصف
تترقب الصين بالمقابل اجتماعات وانشطه
عسكريه مماثله بكثير من التحفظ فوزير
خارجيتها
ستعارض ما وصفه بانه توسع متهور للتحالفات
العسكريه
صداع التحالفات العسكريه الغربيه يزعج
الصين بشكل مزمن وطالما حذرت من عواقب اي
مسعا لانشاء ما تعتبره تحالفا عسكريا على
غرار النيتو في منطقه اسيا والمحيط الهادئ
وحراك واشنطن في هذا السياق لا يخفى ففي
اغسطس الماضي استقبل الرئيس الامريكي
نظيره الكوري الجنوبي ورئيس وزراء اليابان
في قمه تتجاوز حساسيات التاريخ بين جارتي
الصين وترمي لتعزيز التعاون العسكري في
مواجهه بيجين وبيومبيانغ ليس ذلك فقط فثمت
تحالفات حديثه الانشاء مثل اوكوس ويضم
الولايات المتحده والمملكه المتحده
واستراليا واقيم في سبتمبر 2021 ضمن توجه
امريكي بجعل اسيا منطقه ذات اولويه
استراتيجيه قصوى هناك ايضا تحالف كواد
ويضم الولايات المتحده واليابان والهند
واستراليا اعلن قيامه عام 2007 واعيد
احيائه بعد انتخاب الرئيس الامريكي جو
بايدن اواخر 2021
تحالفات تترقبها الصين بريبه ومحاولات
مضاده تبقي منطقه المحيطين الهندي والهادئ
بؤره التوتر واهتمام لا ينقطعان
وفي سياق التوتر في شرق اسيا ايضا انهت
وحدات من رابطه اسيان اول تدريبات عسكريه
مشتركه لها على الاطلاق في بحر نتونس
الشماليسيا
انه بحر اتون الشمالي الذي يقع الى الجنوب
من بحر جنوب الصين ليست اندونيسيا غافله
عن اهميته في ظل تنافس صيني امريكي على
بسط النفوذ في شرق اسيا
قطرها 1000 كيلومتر تشمل كلالمبور
وسنغافوره وهو برونايدر السلام وعندما
نوسع الدائره بقطر الفين كيلومتر فكل
عواصم دول اسيان تدخل في تلك الدائره ومن
ثم اهميتها الجيوستراتيجيه
نحو 60 الف سفينه تمر ببحر جنوب الصين
الواصل بين شرق اسيا والمحيط الهندي نسبه
كبيره منها تتخذه ممر نحو بحر ناتونه وهو
اقرب الممرات واقلها كلفه لمن يبحر باتجاه
الشرق الاوسط واوروبا او ياتي منهما
بحر ناتونا فيه كثير من الثروات الطبيعيه
وهو منطقه مهمه لدول عده لذا من المحتمل
ان يكون لاي دوله لها حدود مع هذه المنطقه
طموح في الاستكشاف والتنقيب عن ثرواتها
لهذا نريد التاكيد من جانبنا على اهميه
موقعنا
وهذا سبب وجيه يدفع اندونيسيا الى تنظيم
مناورات عسكريه في بحر ناتونا واخرها مع
جيرانها من دول اسيا لاسيما اثر تكرار نشر
الصين خريطه تزعم فيها سيادتها على مياه
بحر جنوب الصين المحاذيه لبحر ناتونا
في ظل توتر يتصاعد في جنوب شرق اسيا
وتجاذب مزاعم السياده على المياه والجزر
في بحر جنوب الصين او بالقرب منه تسعى
اندونيسيا ودول اسيان الى ترسيخ حضورها في
مياهها وجزرها الاقليميه كبحرناتون
الشمالي ظل اهميه الاستراتيجيه
والاقتصاديه والملاحيه
المسؤولون المحليون في جزر ناتونا يطالبون
بجعل جزرهم منطقه اقتصاديه خاصه واعانه
الصيادين وحمايتهم
ما نحتاج اليه نحن الصيادين هو الشعور
بالامن لان موقع ناتونا حدودي مع دول
كثيره لذلك فان صيادي تلك الدول يتسللون
الى بحارنا فنشعر اننا مهددون خصوصا خلال
السنوات الثلاث الماضيه حيث تزايدت اعداد
سفن الصيد الاجنبيه في بحر ناتون الشمالي
كما يطالب الصيادون بملاحقه سفن الصيد
الاجنبيه واغراقها وهي سياسه كانت متبعه
سابقا لسنوات وساعدت الصيادين المحليين
على مضاعفه ما يصيدونه وتصديره حيث يوجد
في بحر ناتونا نحو ربع الثروه السمكيه في
البلاد
صهيب جاسم الجزيره بحرنا تونه شماليه
اندونيسيا
[موسيقى]
في فقره المتابعه من حصاد الليله نعود الى
تصريحات نائب رئيس مجلس الامن القومي
الروسيه حول تداول الخيارات امام موسكو
ومنها خيار المواجهه المباشره مع النيتو
في غبره الحرب الروسيه في اوكرانيا زادت
المخاوف بالفعل من اي اشتباك عسكري بين
الجانبين مع ضم حلف في شمال الاساسيه
اخيرا كلا من السويد وفنلندا
التي تشترك بحدود بريه مع روسيا يفوق
طولها الفا وثلاث مئه كيلو متر ويستدعي
هذا الوضع ومقارنه بين القدرات العسكريه
لدول الاطلسي وقدرات روسيا التي تحتل
المركز الثاني في تصنيف اقوى جيوش العالم
بين مليون و300 الف جندي اينما يضم حلف
الناتو سبعه وعشرين جيشا من بينها الجيش
الامريكي الذي يحتل صداره تصنيف الجيوش
عالميه
من حيث القوه الجويه تتفوق جيوش دول
النيتو بنحو ثمانيه عشر الف طائره مقاتله
مقابل 4000 طائره حربيه فقط تمتلكها روسيا
اما بالنسبه للاسطول البري
فترجح كفه روسيا بامتلاكها نحو 22 الف
مدرعه
مقارنه بنحو 16 الف مدرعه فقط في حوزه
اكبر سبعه جيوش حلف شمال الاطلسي
لكن من ناحيه القدرات العسكريه البحريه
طبعا يتفوق النيتو لانه لديه
1145 سفينه حربيه بين بلد روسيا
630 حربيه فقط فيما يتعلق بالترسانه
النوويه للقوه النوويه ثلاث في الحلف وهي
الولايات المتحده وبريطانيا وفرنسا تبلغ
جامعا سته الاف
وخمسه وستين راسا حربيا نوويا بينما تمتلك
روسيا
620055 راس سنويا بحسب ارقام تقديريه ومع
ذلك يستبعد خبراء عسكريون ان تتوجه او ان
تتوجه وتحلف النيتوروسيا بشكل مباشر في اي
مرحله من مراحل الصراع غير ان الجانبين
يتاهبان لكل احتمال بطبيعه الحال
حتى قبل حرب اوكرانيا شكل الدول البلطيق
الخاصره الرخوه الجزء الاوروبيه من
الاطلسي وينتشر في هذه الجمهوريات وبولندا
4000 جنديا من النيتو وعدد مماثل من
الجنود من رومانيا
ارتفع عدد القواعد العسكريه الامريكيه في
اوروبا بعد حرب اوكرانيا الى 50 قاعده
عسكريه تنتشر بين غرب القاره وشرقها اما
موسكو فعززت بدورها امنها العسكري على
المحورين الغربي والشمالي واولد اهميه
خاصه لاصول بحر البلطيق الذي تعتبره حائط
صد على حدودها الجنوبيه
كما رفع الروس منسوب التوتر النووي الى
ذروته الصيف الماضي وبداوا نشر اسلحه
نوويه التكتيكيه في اراضي حليفتهم بيلا
للمزيد
العقيد الكسن
الرئيس تحرير المجال العسكريه السويسريه
سد
استمعت الى تصريحات
نعلم ان له تصريحات حاده وهو عاده ما يكون
اكثر حده من كل المسؤولين الروس لكن يقول
ان الخيارات ضاقت هل تعتبر انها ضاقت
بالفعل وان الموجهه العسكريه مع النيتو
يمكن ان تحدث
نوعا من امواجها او منافسه طبعا هناك
منافسه من نوع معين يمكن ان تحصل ولكن
مواجهه مباشره بين حلف شمال الاطلسي
والروسيا
برايي سوف يشكل ذلك اشكاليه كبيره
علق بما ذكرناه قبل قليل
بالقدرات يعني ما الذي يمكن ان يجر
الجانبين الى هذه الحرب مع النظر الى هذه
القدرات التي تحدثنا عنها ومنها القدرات
النوويه التي يمكن ان تدمر كوكب الارض
مرات ومرات
حسنا انا لا اود ان اعود الى كل المناقشات
التي حصلت منذ سنوات طويله بالنسبه الى
المواجهه النوويه الدرس المستخلص او
الحكمه من الحرب البارده هي ان هذه
الاسلحه هي ضروريه ويجب ان يكون هناك
توازن معين كي لا تستخدم هذه الاسلحه اما
بالنسبه الى الاسلحه التقليديه طبعا هناك
بعض الامور التي يمكن ان نتناقش بشانها
يعني انت تستبعد حرباويه لكن هل بالفعل ما
يحدث في اوكرانيا هو نوع من الحرب
التقليديه بين روسيا والنيتو
نحن نتحدث عن حرب تقليديه للغايه طبعا
دائما ما نحب ان نسمي الامور ونتحدث عن
عقائد عسكريه جديده اذا اليوم على سبيل
المثال وفي هذه الحرب هناك حديث في مستوى
البنتاجون على مستوى البن تاغون عن
الابعاد السته للحرب الحرب في اوكرانيا
تحصل في الاجواء وبرا وفي البحار
وبالاضافه الى ذلك هناك الغواصات ولكن
ايضا هناك حرب الكترو مغناطيسيه اذا الحرب
السايبرانيه تستخدم كذلك والمعلومات
تستخدم والفضاء ايضا اصبح من بين الابعاد
المرتبطه بالمواجهه الجديده التي يمكن ان
تؤخذ يتحدث عن الابعاد السته للحرب ولكن
في الحقيقه يمكن ان نقارن عما يحصل الان
مع امور كانت تحصل في السابق منذ 50 سنه
او 100 عام
هنالك سيناريوهات لا نعرفها بعد لكن ما هي
العلامات الخطر التي اذا حدثت يمكن ان
نقول ان هنالك مواجهه ما ستحدث
اعتقد ان
المخاطر ليست في المكان الذي نتوقعه ولذلك
بدات بالحديث وقلت نعم يمكننا ان نعد
الرؤوس النوويه ونتحدث عن الترساله
الترسانه النوويه وذلك حصل منذ سنوات ولكن
ولا اي سلاح نووي استخدم وبالتالي اعتقد
انه على الارجح يجب ان نركز على التهديدات
الجديده والمخاطر الجديده وعدد كبير من
هذه المخاطر لا نعرفها ولدينا تجربه
محدوده في تلك المجالات على سبيل المثال
المثيرات وذكاء الاصطناعي والمجالس
السيبراني لانه باستطاعه الاطراف ان تطلق
شتى انواع الفيروسات والاسلحه وليس
باستطاعتنا ان نتحكم بالفيروسات على اجهزه
الكمبيوتر على سبيل المثال وهناك الذي
يعرقل هذه القدرات شكرا جزيلا جزيلا لك
رئيس المجله العسكريه السويسريه
[موسيقى]
النووي جديد يمكن ان يؤدي الى فناء
البشريه تحذير لم ياتي من خبراء او مركز
ابحاث بل من الامين العام للامم المتحده
انطونيو الذي قال امام الجمعيه العامه
للامم المتحده اليوم الختامي لجلستها
السنويه ان عدد الاسلحه النوويه يمكن ان
يرتفع لاول مره منذ عقود اي استخدام
للاسلحه النوويه بغض النظر عن المكان او
الزمان او الظروف من شانه ان يطلق العنان
لكارثه انسانيه ذات ابعاد هائله يضيف
بوتارش هو تحذير يتزامر مع ارقام تتكرر
حول تزايد قياسي في عدد الجوعه عبر العالم
وكوارث انسانيه تعجز حكومات العالم خصوصا
النابيه عن مواجهه تكلفتها وتداعيتها ديون
ايضا تتراكم على كثير من البلدان ومع ذلك
نتمنى لنا ولكم عالما اكثر توازنا وامانا
الختام الحصاد لكم تحياتنا والقاكم وسيله
على راس السعاده
[موسيقى]